You started a company when you started Twitter,
when you guys first started,
did you have any I look,
there's no way you could have added any idea what it would be now.
No,
but one of the things I was trying to emphasize with people and then people are
like,
ah,
Twitter is crazy.
And like,
how could it not be crazy?
There's never been anything like it before.
Like imagine trying to predict the kind of,
the president of United States uses Twitter to threaten other countries.
Yeah.
I mean,
who the fuck saw that comment?
Nobody saw that coming.
What did you think it was going to be when you first did it?
Well,
you know,
we were building this thing for ourselves and that's how that,
that's how everything starts.
We wanted to use it.
We wanted to,
we wanted to,
you know,
stay connected with each other.
We text like a group text.
We loved our phones.
We loved,
um,
technology.
We actually started this as a hack week project out of a failed company called
Odeo.
There's podcasting,
I remember that super early on.
We were,
uh,
were really creative folks,
but we weren't that passionate about where podcasting was going in our
particular,
um,
domain.
We just got a lot of competition early on.
Itunes just released their podcast directory.
But we knew we wanted to work together.
We knew,
um,
we love this idea of one button publishing.
We love this idea of collaboration.
We love this idea of uh,
being anywhere and being able to share what was happening.
That was,
that was the idea.
I mean,
that,
that was it and that's what we wanted it to be.
And I think the most beautiful and also sometimes uncomfortable aspect of
Twitter is it,
um,
we really learned what it wanted to be and the people helped create it.
Like everything that we hold sacred now,
the at symbol,
the Hashtag the retweet,
those were not invented by me or the company.
Those were things that we discovered,
things that we discovered people using.
And we just observed it and we,
we noticed what they were trying to do.
They're trying to talk with one another.
They were trying to,
um,
collect tweets around topics with the Hashtag.
Has anybody figured out when the first use of Hashtag something
was created?
Yeah,
it was,
um,
he was actually our lead designer.
Uh,
Robert Anderson who leads our design of the cash app,
um,
hired him for a square,
uh,
later on.
But,
uh,
he was the first one.
He was actually communicating with his brother and uh,
he put at buzz,
his brother's name is buzz and it just kind of spread.
It wasn't in mass,
but people were doing it.
But what was most interesting is not what they're doing,
but what they wanted to do with it.
They wanted to address each other and that's,
that changed the company completely.
That changes the service because they went from just broadcasting what's
happening to conversation and to being,
being able to address anyone publicly out in the open,
which came with it.
A lot of power and also a lot of issues as well.
Yeah.
The,
the use of hashtags like,
uh,
looking up Hashtag you know,
fry fest or Hashtag,
you know,
anytime there's something weird that's in the news that's a,
that's such a unique way to find things but to go on Twitter and to,
to utilize that.
It's a,
I mean it's,
it's interesting that your f that this guy just did it just to contact his
brother.
Well that would,
that was the symbol of the Hashtag was this Guy Christmas ina and he was trying
to,
he was trying to tag um,
here's uh,
trying to tag around topics that he was tweeting about.
And again,
that spread,
all we did was made it easier.
We made it more accessible.
We enabled everyone to do it.
Uh,
with the at symbol,
we made a page that collected all mentions of your name with the Hashtag we
allowed people to search a immediately so you could tap on the keyword and you
would see everyone talking about that or tweeting about that specific Hashtag.
So these things were just emergent behaviors that we didn't predict and they
became the lifeblood of the service.
What's fascinating to me about something like Twitter or even something like
youtube is that there's not a lot of other ones like it.
There's just this one thing like how does that happen where this one thing sort
of gets adopted by everybody and takes over and then just becomes this
overwhelmingly massive platform.
I mean there's really,
there's Vimeo and this is a few other videos,
services,
but nothing on the scale of youtube.
And that's the same thing with Twitter.
There's nothing on the scale of distributing information in a quick,
short,
280 character form like that.
We,
um,
I,
I don't think we could plan for it.
I don't think we could necessarily billed for that.
I,
uh,
someone said recently to,
we just gathered a bunch of our leadership last week in palm springs for an
offsite and someone said recently the Twitter was discovered.
And I think what's behind all that is that it,
it,
it hits something foundational.
It hit something essential.
And my cofounder Biz likes to say that Twitter can never be uninvented.
It's here.
It changed everything though.
The use of it has been revolutionary,
and it's just a simple idea of,
you know,
if you could text with the entire world,
if you could actually reach anyone in the world,
or anyone could see what you're thinking,
which I think is also the beautiful thing about,
about text and the,
and the medium,
you can actually get it.
Someone's raw thoughts and anyone in the world can see that instantaneously.
It becomes a subconscious.
It becomes this like global consciousness and it a,
it gets to some really deep places in society and some of those places are
pretty uncomfortable.